I prepared a couple of cool positions
for you guys the main topic for this
lecture will be about getting your night
to the f5 square is a potential outpost
and how strong and some of the benefits
of such an achievement could be so this
first game here came from a Kings Indian
defense you can tell by the dark squared
bishop on g7 and the the locked pawns in
the center d65 against white spawns d4
and d5 and earlier in the game I'll show
you guys real quick black play this move
Knight h5 attacking white stark scored
bishop and white played h4 and the point
of this move was of course to open the H
file and try to attack blacks King and
these kind of flank attacks are
generally most effective when the center
is closed because otherwise it would
just be to weakening for your position
if the center is kind of opened up and
black and get immediate counter play but
here the center is close to I can sort
of leave their King in the center for
now and try to attack on the King side
so black took this bishop you capture
this pawn in h4 maybe it would have been
better to play g4 to try and keep the
King side closed at after Knight H to h5
i think white still has a lot of options
here to create a powerful attack and
also the F file is really a really
useful asset for white I think they
could consider castling here because now
their King is super safe on the h1
square and the rook is super active on
the F file or they could also consider
like a move Knight f1
with the idea to play 93 and then get to
f5 anyway and launch an attack on the
kingside but maybe that was a more solid
option for black and the game black
decided to take on h4 y point Knight
takes h4 and Queen g5 so this was bikes
idea they figured this g3 pawn was
incredibly weak you know that they can
get immediate counter play by activating
their queen and going after this G pawn
but probably the player playing black
hair missed White's next idea which is
to play Bishop g4 so the pawn is
protected for the moment and if Queen
III check I think white can just play
something like King f1 Queen takes g3
and maybe Knight f5 and the point being
to sacrifice this G pawn but get the
Knight to f5 over the tempo and really
get closer to blacks King something
really similar happened to this in the
game so we'll just take a look at that
but basically after Knight c5 black
who's attacking the bishop on g4 with
their Bishop and why it is pretty much
forced to sacrifice the pawn on g3 which
was of course White's idea so why play
Bishop takes the 8 Queen takes g3 check
King f1 and now rook takes c8 swipe play
Knight f5 Queen f4 check and Queen f3
so what's idea is pretty brilliant
actually because they gave up this pawn
but they got that our Knight to this
awesome square on f5 and they're even
willing to trade Queens because that
would open up the G file and even though
black is upon ahead their Bishop on g7
is a huge target for White's pieces so
next white will play rook g1 and bike is
going to have a hard time defending
his position even if like king h7 rook
g1 Rick g8y can do something like kinky
to double the rooks on the G file and
and block is going to be in huge trouble
they also have the immediate move 97
forking blacks rooks winning an exchange
but the main point of white sacrifice is
of course to create this target on g7
and activate the rooks along the G and H
files and really cause a lot of grief so
any questions so far
I know you just walked in but no problem
yeah any questions on any of that so far
cool dr. Queen f3 black played King h7
and white played King e2 really nice
smooth bass achill ii the king is
perfectly safe on e2 and next why it's
probably gonna play rook f1 and enforce
black to trade Queens or even a move
like rook h4 and ask block to trade
Queen so that they can win in the
endgame
so rook h8 was played rock h4 black
traded g8 rook h1
this is a really strange move for okay
eight but basically does anyone see why
it's immediate threat here
well if Knight takes bishop black will
play King takes and h6 is defended but
you have something even stronger
yeah let's say black just plays on some
random of a six
yeah very good
rook takes h6 takes and we get this nice
mate so for that reason black um had to
move the rook out of g8 to give their
king of square so they decided to play
rook a8 and now who can see a good way
for white to increase the pressure here
on blacks position basically they're
nine and two rooks are perfectly placed
and they can take this pawn on h6 but
white basically white wants to play for
more if they play Knight takes h6 black
will take with the bishop they'll take
with the rook King g7 and white doesn't
really have a good move there they won
back their pawn but they didn't really
get much of anything else that's a good
idea that looks like that wins a pawn
right I guess c7 is hanging and then
Africa c8 will take on a 7 but you can
play for even more than that
yeah B 497 and not a whole lot but you
had the right idea at first we want to
get our c3 Knight into the game somehow
exactly very good
so the second Knight comes to e3 and
from there can either go to G for
attacking h6 or it'll even come to f5 to
replace um the first night and this plan
is completely crushing black really
doesn't have any defense for it
they put 97 93 and King g8 was played
but if a 6y can sacrifice the rook again
and this basically leads to decisive
material advantage 97 check and if King
g7 who can find the best move here
yeah exactly other night comes Steph
five so this is the point set this other
and I can come to f5 King f8 and white
mates
so black played King g8 pretty much the
only defense to to this threat of taking
on h6 and now it's time for white to
switch targets so what would be the
winning plan here basically white plays
- pretty natural moves and black resigns
yeah very good I'm just bringing both
risks to the G file and black has no way
of defending their Bishop rook g1 okay @
7 @ g4 in black resign they're losing
the piece no matter what and with it the
game so what's cool about that game is
that it it shows how strong whites and I
can be even in the endgame a lot of
people assume that you can only attack
when the Queen's are on but of course
that's just not true if the opponent's
king is weak then you can attack as long
as you have a few pieces on the board
still and this is what I wanted to show
you guys why basically sacrifices pawn
on g3 which looks very risky because the
Queen gets so close to White's King but
clearly White's off further and was able
to evaluate this position as being very
good for them eventually white plays
rook h4 forces wipe Detroit Queens opens
the G file and there's just there's too
many threats against blacks blacks Kings
side so any questions on that this is
the game between um URI Bala Shaw was
playing white against Jonathan Penrose
there are both grandmasters so this next
game follows the the same strategic idea
of sacrificing to bring the Knight to f5
and cause a lot of danger to Black's
King but here white sacrificed a full
piece as we'll see
so this is a really interesting moment
actually why play Knight g4 and
attacking the e5 pawn and kind of
inducing block to play f6 which might
have not been a very good idea because
now blacks King side is uh has been
weakened and then white played Queen d2
threatening some kind of Knight h6 check
black plate h5 weakening themselves even
further and why it went back with 93
so why played there Knight to g4 can do
some weaknesses and now white is ready
to attack so by play Bishop d6 and here
originally I was looking at this move h4
because I was trying to find a way for
white to create a decisive attack so the
point of H forced to play g4 next and
open up blacks King and this is a decent
idea white definitely could have played
this and it's gonna be hard for black to
defend our position here g4 is gonna
come and I'll just show you guys let's
say brick B 8 g4 takes Bishop takes and
White's Bishop comes to e6 next and h5
is another idea and basically blacks
King is slowly getting more and more
open and as you can tell all the blacks
pieces are on the Queen side and not
really contributing to the fight which
is taking place on the King side and
another thing I want to point out here
is that the center is again kind of
closed
that's why white is able to make moves
like h4 and g4 which normally would
expose our own King but here because the
center is locked up it's not so easy for
black to long punish white for you know
extending themselves so far out but
playing white here was bitterly check
over probably a grandmaster from 1934
his opponent was vladimir alisov
another GM this was in the championship
of the USSR back in 1934
and he came up with this idea Bishop
takes h5 which is pretty pretty
ingenious I always like looking at games
from like 70 years ago because they
didn't really have so many books and
resources to study like we do so it's
kind of interesting that these players
just came up with all these strategic
ideas on their own that we get to learn
from now exactly right so he gives up
his Bishop for a pawn but after Knight
f5 white is getting a really dangerous
attack the immediate threat is Queen h6
but another idea for white that's very
strong is to play rook III and rook g3
bringing the rook into the game so black
played Bishop f8 the most natural move
getting the bishop out of the attack and
defending the h6 square-y played rookie
three one idea is to play rook g3
another idea is to play Rick h3 and just
go after the h5 pawn and try to
checkmate along the h-file and even
though White's down a piece here it's
hard to really believe that black has a
good defense here because their pieces
are on the Queen side and not really
participating the defense like the
bishop on a6 and the rook on a eight
rook on c eight I mean it's like they're
not even in the game but White has a
knight a rook and the Queen already to
attack black skank so a lot of times
it's really useful to just count the the
material that's actually relevant to the
attack so here White's Knight rook and
Queen are fighting against Blacks Bishop
their 997 and their queen so basically
when it comes to the attack you know
white is doing very well
so King at 7 sorry
Queeny to attacking h5 pawn queen e8
rook h3 and very difficult position for
black definitely losing rook takes h5 is
next followed by bringing the Queen to
g4 and whites attack is too strong so a
cool line here is Queen g6 rook takes h5
King g8 and now rook h3 just going back
threatening rook g3 so King f7 Knight h4
and I was just finding these interesting
lines just for curiosity but basically
blacks queen is can't stay on g6 and has
to allow whites Queen into the attack so
something like Queen g5 we even have the
ship c1 very nice move Queen goes back
Queen h5 check out of five and in black
Swain actually ends up trapped they have
to deal with their Bishop with Bishop g7
but of course White's attack is pretty
devastating
maybe Queen h7 next with threats rook
takes d7 and Rick g8
so instead of queen g6 black could fly a
Bishop g7 now Rick takes h5 queen g4 and
the threat Queen takes g7 um there's
just no good defense for it like if
Queen f8 probably um let's see what can
we do here who can find the force twin 9
h6 looks good and then after King h8
okay and then King g8 you're almost
there
just got to find one more strong move
beautiful very good guys so check King
moves check yeah and Roque Chet would
win the Queen and I mean the night on d7
is also hanging so that's definitely
winning for white because they have the
Queen and you know a strong attack but
uh Queen G said actually Queen g6
doesn't work I'm sorry cuz Queen takes
f7 but I missed that too so no worries
but I know I think this is is enough for
the win King takes and maybe start with
this move King has to go to g6 and I
don't even I don't even want to take the
Queen here I just want to bring my rook
back and go for me but either way a
position like this is winning for white
at the very least we can take this
bishop and looks like we have a queen
for a rook and Knight a couple of extra
pawns and in box King is you know is
going to be weak until we finally
checkmate it so I like that example a
lot it's kind of a bit more radical than
the previous one because white basically
sacrificed an entire piece
just to get this outpost for their nine
and f5 and now and now they don't even
have so many concrete threats like after
Bishop FA basically White has to make
like three more moves before they make
an actual threat but blacks position is
so passive that there's not a whole lot
they can really do to stop this so white
brings the rook in and and here the game
is basically over actually black took on
H five here kind of a desperate move but
Queen takes g7 and that was it so I want
to move on to kind of a longer example
but a really really instructive one
about how how this nine on f5 can just
ruin blacks entire position playing
white here is the great garry kasparov
this is from 1980 so he was still pretty
young i think like seventeen years old
and his opponent is maia chiburdanidze
a-- who is a very good female
Grandmaster I think so yeah so she was
incredibly talented
so it all starts with this move g4 again
I think most of these games came from
the Kings Indian defense which is why we
have the lockbox structure in the center
and because Farber plays g4 to start
attacking blacks King and try to attack
along the light squares so the threat of
course to take on h5 now black takes and
white has a good option here they can
either take with the H pawn and open the
H file or take with the bishop and try
to exchange light scored bishops and
open the G file as well so let me go let
me give you guys a second to think about
how you would recapture on g4 either
with the bishop or with the pawn and
this is a really crucial decision with
the pawn
does anyone else also want to capture
with the pawn on g4 I see some head
shaking so with the bishop then
right that definitely makes sense what
about the move rook g1 just right away I
don't know I just noticed that now I
didn't really analyze it before but I
think it's really interesting but maybe
unnecessary in the game because Fargo
just took on g4 with the bishop and I
think this is the the right decision
because blacks LightSquared Bishop is
probably their best defenders
controlling all of these light squares
and by exchanging these bishops they'll
be a lot easier to attack black and
blacks Bishop on g7 is of course a
really passive piece so by play g5 I'm
really not sure about this move maybe
ninety seven was just better just to
keep the bishops on the board I don't
know I think g5 is incredibly weakening
but we won't really analyze it too much
if I played g5 y exchange on c8 and here
bishop g3 and I think White's position
is really good like you know blacks King
on g8 is pretty vulnerable so next we're
gonna play 93 Knight f5 and h4 and open
the H file and eventually Queen f3 and
Castle queenside and black who's a bit
behind in development so they can't
really create any kind of counter play
so far they would love to play like a
six and B five but right now they're
just not developed enough to do it so I
think White's position is just really
good here and probably Kasparov would
win but he decided to just play 93
immediately which is um pretty radical
basically giving up this Bishop on the
spot but getting the Knight f5
immediately and I don't know I mean he
wanted
really brilliant game here and I'm glad
he did because it gives us some
instructive material but I think I mean
I think just retreating the bishop and
playing h4 was also a great option and
you know not as risky because here he is
sacrificing a piece but not if five is
played Queen d8 and his idea is just to
you know triple his heavy pieces on the
G file and try to destroy blacks
position but um you have to see really
far for this to work because it at first
glance it really doesn't look like White
has enough for the attack here because
black has a square and g5 for their
knight seemingly um that should be
enough to sort of defend their position
but Queen g4 Knight g5 and here Knight
takes h4 and this is co sparrows
ingenious idea he just takes this pawn
he's gonna put his knight back on f5 and
then play h4 and kick black's knight so
incredibly you know White's attack is
progressing extremely slow but the
center is closed blacks pieces are still
in the Queen side and there's just not
enough time for them to really set up
some kind of some kind of good defense
here so Rick c7 9 F 5 8 6 H 4 9 8 7 root
G 1
Queen f8 and white actually doesn't have
a breakthrough here just yet
like if h5 black can come back with this
night sorry
it's a g5 so king e - and here I think I
don't know Maya playing black at what
point she realized that she was
completely lost or probably after he
made this move I think she realized that
her position was just pretty much
hopeless
the problem is Black has no counter play
against White's King and why it's just
gonna triple on the G file and
eventually black won't be able to defend
white from breaking through
so Brooke a 7 Mike wants to play b5 and
defend along the seventh rank and I love
this move a for this why does all the
time in the world they can prevent black
from getting any kind of counter play
and they're basically playing down a
piece but it doesn't feel like it with
b6 Queen h5 h8 brings the other rook to
the G file 7 Mike really doesn't have
anything to do other than um other than
wait the knight on b8 has no way of
getting out because it would like if
black played rook f7 and 97 then g7
would would be hanging there and black
doesn't want to play a 5 because White's
other night would come to b5 and then
eventually just take on d6 so queen g4
67 52
king of wine
basically White has all the time they
want black really can't make any kind of
progress but of course eventually
Kasparov has to find a winning plan
because right now g7 is is just
protected enough so ninety-two Queen c8
and here you plays f4 so the idea of
course is that if black takes on f4 and
I takes f4 Knight comes into e6 and
blacks Bishop is just lost White has
five attackers Black has at most four
defenders and that's game over
but of course black doesn't have to take
on f4 but so the real idea of the snow
is that it controls the g5 square and
now I can push their H pawn without
worrying about box Knight coming back to
g5 so really great attacking idea b5 was
played pretty much a desperate try to
get counter play but you know obviously
there's nothing we can suggest for black
here other than doing something doing
anything really that's why he took this
pawn or it could be seven h5 9 f8 here
White has a lot of winds and if you guys
want to try and suggest a winning plan
or winning try for white by all means go
ahead
age six looks pretty good
let's see don't even know what to play
here for Black Knight takes g6 how the
Queen takes bishop takes here would lead
to mate or well devastation
and otherwise why just White's ready to
take on g7 and play Brooke h1 or Ric h2
and blacks King is getting gum made it I
think Rick h6 was also winning Bishop
takes h6 we have Queen g8 checkmate
and that h7 takes h6 this is also good
enough for the win but the move Kasparov
played is maybe even the strongest move
he played Queen h3 so black took and the
idea is to play on h6 so c4h6
how it takes check
and I'm sure there's some night h6 this
is good enough right
I think this is good enough - don't
worry about that yeah that's how winning
this position with white is I mean I I
looked at I with the computer and it's
like you know the top eight moves for
white I like plus for all the way to
like plus eleven so the game concluded
Knight takes G 6hg came there and now
White's not even down material and of
course with the extra piece and Queen h8
next it's black resign so this was
probably you know like the crowning game
of this strategic idea because it's it
was like white blacks position was so
bad that why it was just in no hurry to
really do anything too fast but Kasparov
came up with this ingenious plan to
justify queen g4 and then just take this
pawn and then push the H font I mean I
think that would be really hard to find
during the game because your your
instinct is that white needs to Y needs
to create some threats really quickly
but here what cuz bar realizes that
black was just not in any position to
develop and try to defend his defend his
pieces or as king and why not just
enough time to basically bring all their
pieces to their perfect spot and
eventually breakthrough when your
position is this strong it's um it's
almost impossible not to break through
you know it's just too too perfect
and then this f4 move I really like just
controlling the g5 square and finally
finally bringing the last piece into the
attack the H pawn
yeah oh well that's all I have prepared
for you guys today so stick around